alright I'll get started them so I
thought it'd start with
one of our classrooms looks like to give
you a little bit of a background and the
timeline of our project it actually
started in the mid 2000s with a the
Consortium for language teaching and
learning we formed a small committee and
we traveled among our member
institutions to get a sense of how we
could do more collaborative projects
particularly with respect to less
commonly taught languages that resulted
in a pilot project in the 2011-12
academic year between four institutions
where we share just two languages
Romanian between Columbia and pen and
then Dutch between Cornell and and Yale
and based on that we were approached by
the mellon Foundation and we say it's a
two-year pilots grants to try to see how
we could share these languages and work
on the model so we have we're now in the
second part of the first phase and we're
in the process of writing a continuation
grant which we hope we will receive for
the next three years of the project our
model is different from many of the ones
you may have heard about it Arsene it's
synchronous completely synchronous and
live and we use high-definition video
conferencing so it's not an online
course we use the internet to transmit
the video but that's really about it
it's not online it's not a MOOC it's not
any of the the acronyms that you may
have heard it's a regular course
students come to class if the Yale
students are involved they come to class
five days a week and they are in
connected classroom to classroom to
their peers at another institution and
so it's real time as any regular
classroom would be and it's also
credit-bearing during the academic year
so the students can take these courses
for the language required to fulfill the
language requirements for example or for
many other purposes we also have a lot
of graduate students it's in addition to
the videoconferencing it's a very
multimodal environment so we use many
sources also asynchronous sources as
well our resources as well we have wikis
have we used of course management system
at our institutions we use a grip audio
lab with Cornell we've used Adobe
Connect Pro iPads we also use a Wacom
tablet for various purposes so we use
many other tools in the process I wanted
to show you this image because the
previous image you saw both of the
classrooms in this case the instructor
this is an instructor United two
classrooms but here is an interactive
whiteboard if he uses to project the
text as he works within the classical in
classical Tibetan our mission I'll just
read it so the way we think about it
it's a collaborative model that uses
innovative technology to share academic
resources across institutional
boundaries enabling strategic partners
to enrich existing curricula while
respecting local institutional cultures
we purposely didn't put the word
language in there and I'll come to that
we see this as a model that can be used
for other disciplines as well and for
other purposes and we also put the word
strategic partners in there because one
of the the I think the strength of the
model is that it's connect and allows
collaboration between institutions that
are well well positioned together and so
when we're doing the kind of languages
that we're teaching among Yale Cornell
and Columbia we are like-minded
institutions with very similar goals and
ambitions from what it is that we want
to do with these languages to give you a
little bit of the background it came out
of a number of budgetary cutbacks
particularly federal level with respect
to less commonly taught languages and we
were looking for a solution to maintain
our very broad menu of less commonly
taught languages we had among our
institutions over a hundred languages
across the institutions but we didn't
share most of those and so we saw this
as a way that we could share our
strengths and along the line also within
language teaching we've thought a lot
about combining the global and local and
I'll all come back
in moments but that was one way to think
about it and we also wanted to maintain
the quality language classrooms are
highly interactive they they rely on the
students ability to communicate with
each other with the instructor playing
more of a facilitative role and so we
really wanted to keep that high that
high energy environment and normal
language classroom hands so our
objectives were to expand or maintain
first enrollments to four institutions
that were affiliated to to add more
languages but also to go deeper into the
curriculum a lot of the languages that
we're talking about here are very small
languages that are hardly ever taught
and that have maybe one instructor for
institution and by combining curricula
we can now go deeper next year we'll
start advanced level 3rd year courses in
languages that are very difficult to
maintain enrollments and so we have more
shared curricula in that sense and we
also saw this as a way to bring these
instructors are very isolated on their
campuses together to share professional
development opportunities and best
practices these are a list of the
languages that we have offered thus far
we now have nine there are plans for a
number and more next year including
possibly sinhala Burmese Casa and a few
other ones that are being discussed at
the moment so each year we not only add
languages but we also add levels so this
year we have be giving an intermediate
for example in Bengali and Tamil next
year we'll add an advanced level a third
year of course to that so again some of
the benefits and challenges off the
model the quality is very high it's
reliable it's very close to regular
classroom we allow two teachers just as
what's with what Bill was talking about
it's really driven by the teachers
pedagogy it's it's not constrained by
the technology we want to maintain
even promote more authenticity of
interaction and learner autonomy some of
the challenges have been its of course
it's expensive but that is where the
grant came in we were able to outfit a
number of rooms at each institution to
do this it has to be compatible these
systems have to speak to each other but
don't have to be exactly the same the
coordination is is a challenge we are
very different types of institution with
different cultures we have different
class times we have different semester
schedules we have different language
requirements we have different numbers
of hours per week that we require so we
have to negotiate a lot of that and
that's an ongoing challenge but it's one
that we have been able to very
successfully I think overcome we're
running a parallel research projects and
where we investigate what is happening
with the instructors what's happening
with the students what kind of outcomes
are we seeing and so when we're looking
at some preliminary comments by the
instructors they're very positive and
they see it as a way that helps them
transform their teaching it helps their
pedagogy become even more exciting and
interactive it's a very dynamic way of
having a shared space across different
institutions they feel that they're very
deeply engaged with the student or even
deeper some of them are saying than in a
regular classroom because I think they
feel that to reach out and connect these
two rows requires that they also of
course have very motivated students that
bring interesting perspectives that
might not necessarily be available
locally so we have an advanced dual
course where Michigan students and a
Cornell's join they're both PhD students
that are very deeply involved in study
of South Africa are taking part with
Yale students and bringing very
different experiences so it's an
interesting environment for our students
as well the balance is it's difficult in
the beginning because you have two
classrooms if they tend to focus on the
far end and neglect the students
initially but that's something that they
they get used to very quickly and there
there is so much technology that it
takes the instructors a little while to
fully take advantage of everything the
inter
active smartboard for example is is a
new toy that they all need to learn to
deal with and once they know what what
it can do they like to do that
and I was going to show you if I can
move over real quickly it's a one-minute
video of what's what it looks like this
is an instructor at Columbia teaching
classical Tibetan let's see if anybody's
looking to get to verse 5 okay well
we've got we got a little bit more than
10 minutes left let's see if we can't
make a dent in verse bosses you want to
read it for me Rupa dua don't draw Allah
it's just a little sample so they
there are no constraints they did the
audio the microphones are built into the
ceiling and the students can just speak
freely real-time there's no lag and they
can speak to each other hear each other
see each other all going on at the same
time but the student comment is that we
talked a lot about learner autonomy in
the language classroom making the
students responsible for their own
learning but what we're seeing even more
so in this environment is learning with
what I think'll and learn and control
the far-end has can take control over
the camera angles of of descending in
institutions so if they see something
going on in that classroom if it's a
student giving a presentation or they
want to hear the pronunciation they can
zoom in on a particular student they can
up the volume so they're in control of
what's happening what they find
important something is being written on
a whiteboard they can zoom in on that
and so they're it's not just even being
autonomous but it's also being in
control of learning it's also very much
in in some ways too driven a lot of the
content because these are very less
commonly taught languages they feel that
they have a say in what is going on in
the classroom and there has been an
interesting building of communities
across the distance and and descending
in the receiving institution the
students will meet each other in New
York have dinner together in a Romanian
restaurant and the other thing for
languages is very important is we no
longer do these canned you some of you
may have been exposed to these horrible
language learning pedagogy swear you had
to memorize dialogues and all of that we
know that we haven't done this for a
long time what we're searching for us
authenticity well you get it when you
have students that are in Ithaca and you
want to have a conversation about -
whether well there is a real
conversation that can take place because
you don't know what the weather is like
in Ithaca we've also had one time there
was a exhibit on Dutch culture at the
Museum in at Cornell and the students
took iPads and gave a tour of that
exhibit to the Yale students who could
not physically be
and that's real authentic interaction
they can ask questions about something
that really goes on at the same time
some of the minor challenges mostly it's
not the technology but again some of the
differences in schedules that come up
but again we try to overcome those
through other technical means of
technology some of the implications that
we're seeing and I was sitting at that
in the beginning is that beyond seeing
the less commonly taught languages as
shared resources there is a potential
for replicability and scalability here
the replicability we're already seeing
there are other institutions that are
doing similar things
Duke has has is partnering up with
Virginia Duke and come here to take a
look what we're doing and they're now
doing a similar model some of the small
colleges in Connecticut are doing the
same thing I'm in conversation with some
your European institutions that are
really interested in the model but
beyond that in terms of the scalability
what we mean by that is that we see the
potential for other shared curricula
beyond languages there might be small
seminar courses that could benefit from
having students involved that are
interested in a specific discipline
Columbia is exploring this with a
history graduate course next academic
year for example and so for a small
highly interactive highly specialized
course this might be an interesting
model we're seeing this also as a
transforming of teaching practice
practices by reimagining the classroom
as a as a shared collaborative space by
combining the local and the global some
examples are Columbia is connecting its
classrooms to its its global centers so
there are different ways that we can do
that we also see this at Yale other
language instructors or more commonly
taught languages are bringing in
speakers for example in their classroom
who are native speakers who bring in
cultural ideas into the classroom so
there are many potential uses of the
technology beyond just the small sharing
of languages
I wanted to end with the mission with
the vision which kind of tries to
articulate that so you know we see this
as a as a model that allows us to share
these resources across institutional
boundaries where we can share curricula
and work was an exchange of knowledge
regardless of where that knowledge is
located Thank You namitha for such a
rich presentation and it's the kind of
thing a wonderful example of the sort of
thing that we can all learn from I'm
sure the people sitting room thinking
about how they might be able to take
advantage of some of the have to work
through the same issues that Malecha and
her group have been working working
through we are pretty much on time are
there any questions that you would like
to address to nelligan we could get the
mic to you Lucas here close enough maybe
nips now once you just come up here make
the most effective way for doing this
whether it's an ongoing process
what do you sit down with all the
faculty at the end of the semester sort
of do a debrief on how the semester when
they think about planning for next
semester well we do both so we have at
each institution we have a coordinator
who meets with the faculty to just deal
with the issues most of the time it's
not the technology it's the pedagogy I
want to do this how can I best do that
and we also have our technology support
people that think about pedagogical
practice so that's an ongoing thing we
started a series of online workshop or
our technology mediated workshops video
conferencing workshops on assessment
this semester that are they're meeting
every Friday afternoon with Columbia and
Cornell
I think we had Billy how many we had 32
with Columbia
so it's doctors from other languages
came to this but it was intended for our
instructors but it was so popular that's
we had probably 30 or 40 instructors
total so we tried to do specialized
support and then every year we have a
multi-day workshop where we bring
everyone together we also allowed to
faculty to travel to their students at
the ends of Farsight to meet with the
students and to also connect so we had a
starter from Colombia give a talk and
he'll about his the best instructor gave
a talk about his his research to connect
him to the academic community at the
receiving institution Linda freed by the
use of the iPad at Cornell for looking
at the the exhibition are their ideas of
extending that idea so that instructors
undoubtedly have friends and scollay
acquaintances at the home country of
imagining having I pad conversations
on site with student groups or looking
at the cultural resources of the
countries for whom the language is being
taught that's a great idea at the moment
that's it's something we've put into our
plan to do more explore potential
pedagogical applications of iPad use you
just give a great example these are just
sort of things we want to look at and
and play with and see what what kind of
potential pedagogical advantages okay
anything else